holy [ __ ] these january 6 hearings have
more drama than a daytime soap opera we
found out that rudy giuliani and donald
trump ruined innocent lives in order to
get a second term several politicians
were seeking pardons and trump had a
toddler tantrum when he was told that he
couldn't go to the capitol on january
6th
[Music]
so far we've learned that representative
andy biggs and senator ron johnson both
tried to decertify biden electors and
put forward fake trump electors ron
johnson wanted to hand off fake trump
electors from michigan and wisconsin to
vice president mike pence like it was
some sort of shady back alley drug deal
luckily neither biggs nor johnson were
successful in their scheme and of course
neither one of them have complied with
the subpoenas from the january 6
committee they claim the committee's
investigation is a witch hunt look it's
very simple if they believe what they
did on january 6 was legitimate and that
they're innocent then they have nothing
to hide just comply and testify however
these traders won't do that because they
know what they did was illegal and
reckless i mean just look at rudy
giuliani oh god bad idea can we swap out
the photo
nope
nope
next yeah fine i guess that'll do like i
was saying giuliani knew there was no
fraud but he still kept pushing the big
lie just listen to what giuliani told
arizona house speaker rusty bowers a
republican he said we've got lots of
theories we just don't have the evidence
so despite having no evidence rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis kept calling
people to spread the big lie like they
were those annoying car extended
warranty scammers rusty bowers shared an
emotional testimony about the disturbing
protests that were outside his home in
the impact that it had on his wife and
his daughter who was at home gravely ill
at the time georgia's secretary of state
brad raffensberger the guy that trump
told to find 11 780 votes and thankfully
didn't
shared how the home of his son's widow
had been broken into this is trump's
republican party this is magga they will
attack anything and anyone if their cult
leader says so even if they're
republicans now we already knew that
trump and giuliani were absolute pieces
of trash but holy [ __ ] they steamrolled
innocent people in their attempt to get
a second term shay moss an elections
worker in fulton county georgia who
along with her mother ruby freeman was
falsely accused by giuliani of
committing election fraud of ruby
freeman and shea freeman mars and one
other gentleman
quite obviously surreptitiously passing
around
usb ports as if they are vials of heroin
or cocaine and guess what that usb
device that giuliani kept complaining
about it was a [ __ ] gingerment
giuliani's blatant lies led to
harassment of racist messages and death
threats a lot of threats wishing death
upon me be glad it's 2020 and not 1920.
shane moss and ruby freeman ended up
suing oan and giuliani for defamation
oen was settled out of court but
giuliani has not and honestly i hope
they take giuliani for all he's worth
and more all of these bat-shit crazy
conspiracy theories of voter fraud were
repeatedly debunked by trump doj
officials however trump wanted them to
be true so he kept pushing trump even
wanted to investigate an internet-based
conspiracy theory that an italian
defense contractor had uploaded software
to a satellite that switched votes from
trump to biden oh and just to be clear
these are italian satellites not to be
confused with the jewish space lasers
that marjorie taylor green has talked
about previously so when former acting
attorney general jeffrey rosen and
former acting deputy attorney general
richard donahue rejected trump's
conspiracies trump said you guys may not
be following the internet the way i do i
wish i was surprised by this but then
again trump looked directly at a solar
eclipse without eye protection after
being told not to so
we're not working with an intelligent
person here at this point trump needed
to find himself a yes man and that
person was environmental lawyer jeffrey
clark and if you don't know or remember
who clarke is don't worry he's got a
very punchable i mean a forgettable face
trump offered clark the job of acting
attorney general replacing rosen with
the understanding that clark would send
a letter to georgia that falsely
asserted that the doj had evidence of
election fraud but luckily rosen and
donahue refused to sign it and trump did
not make jeffrey clark the acting
attorney general oh and quick update on
jeffrey clark step on out here come on
this way
can i put pants on first sir we've got
to clear the house we're going to clear
the house as soon as we clear the house
we'll get to talk to your lawyer and
we'll get some pants on okay just a
quick tip for jeffrey clark maybe next
time put some pants on before you answer
the door or you know what better yet
don't attempt a coup and if the hearings
weren't nuts already we found out from
cassidy hutchinson the top aide to the
former white house chief of staff mark
meadows that several politicians were
seeking pardons andy biggs moe brooks
matt gates louis gomer scott perry and
marjorie taylor greene were all ordering
pardons at trump's pardon buffet now i'm
curious why would marjory taylor green
need to ask for a pardon if she took
office on january 3 2021 also matt gates
asked for a blanket pardon as early as
december 2020 for anything and
everything from the beginning of time up
until today
so it sounds like matt gates has more
than just a minor problem in a
last-minute emergency hearing the
january 6 committee revealed a mystery
witness it was none other than cassidy
hutchinson and she revealed what we all
suspected trump is nothing more than a
narcissistic child with a very short
temper on january 6 trump was irate that
many rally attendees were having to go
through metal detectors a standard
security procedure for anyone near the
president but his reasoning to remove
the metal detectors was because it would
give the appearance of more people
attending the rally remember size
matters a lot to trump it's why he made
former press secretary sean spicer talk
about how big his inauguration crowd was
or why he got so mad at stormy daniels
when she talked about how small is
well you know and is the crowd gathered
on january 6th trump was informed that
people had weapons and this is how he
responded they're not here to hurt me
take that thing bags away
let my people in they can march the
capital from here let the people in take
the effing mags away so even though
trump knew that attendees had weapons
he still encouraged them to go to the
capitol anyway walk down and i'll be
there with you
we're gonna walk down
we're gonna walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're gonna walk down to the capitol
even white house counsel pat zippoloni
knew this was a terrible idea mr sabloni
said something to the effect of
please make sure we don't go up to the
capitol cassidy keep in touch with me
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable if we make that
movement happen now this is where things
get interesting as trump was leaving the
rally he got into the suv with secret
service and demanded to be taken to the
capitol and when they wouldn't trump had
a tantrum trying to take control of the
wheel and choking the secret service
agent in the driver's seat but luckily
for the secret service agent trump has
tiny hands this wasn't the only time
that trump had a tantrum before former
attorney general bill barr resigned he
told the associated press in early
december 2020 that there was no evidence
of widespread voter fraud trump went
ballistic he threw his lunch against the
wall breaking a porcelain dish leaving
ketchup dripping down the wall in this
track since we already knew trump likes
ketchup on a stake but trump was not the
only person who was unwilling to accept
a peaceful transfer of power just listen
to general mike flynn during his
deposition general flynn do you believe
in the peaceful transition of power in
the united states of america
wait what was that general flynn do you
believe in the peaceful transition of
power in the united states of america
the fact that mike flynn pled the fifth
to what is a very simple question should
tell you everything you need to know
about him and what his intentions are
and just like trump and his allies
attacked shea moss and her mother ruby
freeman they also attacked cassidy
hutchinson after her testimony many
calling her a liar two problems with
that cassidy was under oath and pat
sipoloni just testified for nearly eight
hours with the january 6 committee
behind closed doors and guess what he
did not contradict what anybody has said
during their testimonies he did not
contradict the
testimony of other witnesses and i think
we did learn a few things
which we will be um
rolling out in the hearings to come so
with more witnesses coming forward to
testify it is obvious that people are
seeing the proverbial ketchup on the
wall well i'm gabe sanchez and this has
been what was that
[Music]